[Music]
so Android fireside chat the first thing
we should do is actually tell you who we
are so you have a little context on the
kinds of things that maybe we can fake
an answer to I'm Chet Haase I'm on the
developer relations team I will not be
answering any questions today Dave Burke
lead to Android engineering and I was
told I'm gonna answer all the hard
questions true I'm Maggie I manage the
Android toolkit team I'm torn or be and
work on Android studio
I'm meat boy I work on Android X
architecture components Harry Potter
brush my body running generic for Play
Store Paul Bankhead product replaced
store and play policy Steph I work on
our developer experience Dan Sandler I
work on Android system UI Dan hack burn
I imagine the android framework team
that does not include any jetpack stuff
and Margalo might work on android core
OS excellent so that's all the people up
here we also have other people in the
audience because this group of people
doesn't know everything that group of
people does so we have many experts here
from the engineering team on Android we
can hopefully answer most of the topics
that are going to come up one important
ground-rule we sort of have a general
policy on the Android of not answering
questions about the future so if your
question begins with when will or are
you planning to your guarantee did not
get a very interesting answer I will
give you a sample what is your favorite
feature in the next release Romo dock
mode
why do I even alright so I had some
content to cover first and then we'll
get into a little bit of Q&A so let me
work through some slides alright let's
get on to the QA here's how it's going
to work there are two mics in the stands
and there are a bunch of questions I
reached out to Twitter for and we're
gonna do a combination of those things
so I'm going to start with some of the
questions that we got from the online
community if you have a question in your
mind please come stand by the mic and
we'll take most of the questions from
the audience and on we go with the
fireside chat so let me start with this
one what are androids team's feelings on
Kotlin native any plans to actively
support it where it is possible or
sensible Steph do you want to oh deer in
the headlights it's just looking at tour
to see I think we're very excited about
colonnade tour and I and the team in
general it's a technology we've been
exploring we're very interested in where
it's going and been collaborating with
the JetBrains team we'll see kind of how
it evolves in the future there we go all
right I see a lot of people lined up at
the mics not okay let me tell you how
short this session is going to be if we
don't get live questions yes hi so
unfortunately for the pixel team the top
two om manufacturers for Android are no
Samsung and I think like algae or Huawei
or something
the unfortunate thing about that is that
both of these OMS have known quirks
around things like Bluetooth and camera
the unfortunate part about that besides
that being a pain for all of us here is
that these are the ambassadors for
Android these are the touch points for
the for the Android operating system
most people are familiar with like a lot
of people if you ask them what kind of
phone do you have they say I don't have
a Samsung they don't say I have an
Android phone so given that this is the
touch point for Android this is the this
is how most people interact with Android
not through Google specifically but
through these OEMs and given that
there's all of these pain point
around camera that that have been
addressed now with camera acts and and
Bluetooth and all of these Hardware
sensors what's what's the long-term
vision for ensuring that OMS are
adhering to some sort of standard around
how they're how they're integrating
hardware with with the operating system
and what what's the plan to make sure
that developers don't have to bash their
heads in with things like Bluetooth in
years to come
just to be clear where you don't
encourage bashing heads in as a
developer community it's not a policy
sometimes it's necessary though so I
mean our role is to make sure that when
you write an application that it runs
everywhere on all devices with as much
consistency as possible obviously the
goal would be perfect consistency and
the way we ensure consistency as you
probably know is we have these CTS tests
compatibility test suites that all
device makers have to run we also have
something called VTS now which is set of
tests at the treble at the hardware
level which also have to pass and even
more so those tests have to pass with it
what we call a generic system image from
Android on top of their implementation
and so what we've been doing is
investing more and more into the
infrastructure the number of tests how
they run test tools and as we invest
more we start improving the consistency
and I think what you were saying which i
think is fair is that we still got work
to do to make it more consistent and so
we're definitely investing there the
other thing that's in U and Q which you
may have heard about is Android mainline
and so now we have the ability to push
select OS modules and the way that works
is it's still open source but we work
with all of our partners to upstream
their changes so we have a common
mainline and then we push these modules
I had in the Train and so in queue for
example we have media codecs and media
extractors that are standard and they're
you know often pain points for media
developers app developers using media
and so that brings consistency as well
as security benefits so anyway it's an
ongoing I think that
that we're constantly working towards
and if anyone else wants dad
good thanks hi hi
as a user I actually have a multi voice
assist in the household I have Alexa and
Google home and I don't have a third but
I could theoretically potentially have
one and one of the things I love about
my phone is that I can act as both
Google and Alexa on it but with the
changes a lot of it seems like a lot of
permissions and abilities are being
restricted to the default voice
assistant and I wondered if there was
any ability or ways that you could see
having multiple voice assistants on your
phone and being able to just invoke
Alexa or Google or Bixby just by using
that particular wake word on your phone
I had a question for you first do you
find that they talk about you when
you're not around yes a lot so on to
your question is assistant do you know
what things do you think are being
restricted because I don't know that we
well I do know that the there's a
permission bundled with default voices
isn't the ability to access your call
logs and I'm guessing just based on that
type of thing that more types of
behavior like that will fall under the
default voice assistant category and
thus will be unable to be accessed by
the regular assistant I don't think we
just removed call log access as far as I
know we haven't we haven't pushed any
functionality to only the assistant or
whoever the default voice interaction
service is well in addition to
permissions there's also the voice
interaction service which gets callbacks
and you only get that if you're the
default voice assistant yeah that's been
the design since the beginning of that
is that you pick one pick one assistant
on your device and there's only one and
there's a lot of reasons for that you
know like the always always on hot work
detection you know like is barely works
for one I mean barely as far as like
being able to customize it and stuff I
don't mean it doesn't what doesn't
really means
and there's you know and there's like
you know the gesture to bring up the
assistant is tied to that and so if you
have multiple ones you know like it
doesn't it's not clear what should
happen in that case and there's a lot of
resources associated with it because
those things need to always be running
like part of the expectation is you're
always reading star always listening to
the microphone and so so it was a very
conscious decision that you can have one
assistant on your device and we and I
mean that hasn't changed in queue that's
been always the case work and yeah I
don't we have no Haven plans to change
that but there you can have one
assistant and you can change it for
people who don't know all right
thanks Michael I've got a question about
expanded screenshots or scrolling
screenshots so recently I read a bell
there was a request about getting a this
into Android there's several OEMs who've
done this but Google recently said
they're they're not gonna do it I think
initially they said they they might look
into it but doctor ticket was changed to
say it's not gonna happen could you talk
some about so I didn't I don't know who
said it's not gonna happen but that's
not what are you doing tomorrow I think
it's a good idea I haven't talked to
talk to the team I think it's a good
idea but maybe Tom's gonna tell me why
it's not a good idea no I would I would
I wouldn't dream of it done yeah I mean
there's no reason not to do it it seems
like a good idea we just have to
prioritize it and everything else
exactly thank you thanks patches welcome
thank you yeah any other feature
requests anybody yes hi so one thing
that I'm noticing is you know I have a
lot of friends who have iPhones and I
keep donors like you should come to the
Android voice and the number one thing
that I keep getting as like the I don't
want to do it yet is because it doesn't
have iMessage and you know we have our
messaging platforms that we've tried in
the past and historically they have not
been great or they have been killed and
you know I want to be able to see like a
version of iMessage that could come to
Android that is either supported and
continued to be built a pond or is
agreed upon by all the OEMs that
necessarily do it and I'd probably
assume we're gonna say you know
new text rich-text informant but I'm
definitely curious about all of that to
like fix this we can kind of say like no
no we have something even better than
iMessage yeah super conscious of the eye
message situation it depends in
different regions like you know from
Ireland and whatsapp is the thing and so
it doesn't come up very often that's
what people use there you know it's
interesting if you look at what happened
you know we had text messaging right and
uh and then you had over-the-top
messaging services like I a message
whatsapp signal etc and they you know
they pushed far ahead of text messaging
they didn't have restrictions they had
more multimedia you can see when the
person's typing you get read receipts
all that kind of stuff and so what's
happened is regular SMS has got left
behind and and the work that we've been
doing and you're right I was gonna say
RCS this is the new IMS standard we've
been working on that and working with
carriers and working with device makers
to basically bring SMS up to that level
so that that capabilities available in
your phone and and it becomes less it
becomes more standard effectively and so
that's the approach that we've been
taking but it's it takes time to work
through all the carrier standards and to
get adoption but we're making progress
on it but you're not gonna kill it right
like we're gonna keep killing or do go
wish okay thank you
Thanks I'm gonna reach out to online
again to ask yeet the Android X
artifacts often seem like everything's
an alpha beta RC which is a hard sell in
some companies where they demand that
you use stable releases are there good
ways to help smooth this out actually
try to touch this in our what is new
talk so there's there's two problems
here one is libraries which already
reached a stable and they go back to
offer quickly because while trying to
stabilize the library there's the result
of things we want to implement we cannot
so I say this stable want to put them in
you are like free to use the stable
version and the other part is these like
something we announced it like we
announced work manager navigation lost
IO it took them like six to eight months
to become stable we want to short
that time but we also once you go stable
like somebody's going to use it you need
to support that API forever so I want to
make sure that's like a very good API so
we will try to do better on that end and
when we call something beta that's
pretty good to use on production isn't
very good there's also the fact that we
have something like 70 libraries in
jetpack now so of course this will
always one that will be now for beta so
it feels like a lot of libraries so what
I'm hearing is that we should do less
and stop working you're on vacation now
hi is there anything that you'd be
willing to share about fuschia OS I mean
I know there's a lot of curiosity
surrounding it and to the best of my
knowledge it hasn't really been
discussed at i/o so far do you have a
slide that says fuschia fireside chat I
could put up there just joking I mean
it's really question for the future team
I so I don't really have much to add I
you know there's there's some good
collaboration happening between the
teams like this year it's give you two
examples as one is we have this angle
driver on queue and the idea is that we
have a module to mainline module and it
implements OpenGL ES 2.0 just finishing
that off and soon 3.0 and it runs on top
of Vulcan and we actually developed that
with fuchsia because fuchsia uses Vulcan
at the base level for graphics like like
Android isn't that migrated to he's
migrating to instead we work closely
they're also on jet pack compose which
is our new UI toolkit you know we worked
very closely with a flutter team one of
the things that we care about is having
I care about is in particulars is having
transferable skills like so if you know
flutter you should be able you know the
toolkit and Android should look familiar
to you too so you can move between them
and that's something we've done a
collaboration but so so our you know our
viewpoint of futures more about the
things we're doing with them but I can't
really speak to exactly their project so
I'll get it all wrong so okay thank you
Thanks hi
nope yeah basically care just once to
ask the same okay all right good thank
you Dave do you want to say that again
yeah outside again so hi hi so in past
two years we had bwa and we had amp and
we had instant ab but I feel like they
they are competing each other so I had
the opportunity to do amp and instant
app at the same time and when we
released a production the analytics got
skewed because when we have instant app
the traffic's cannot reroute to the apps
and our sales going to shift from the
web sales to the app sales so my
question is so when when you guys
release the product what's what's the
thinking behind it like the drill using
two products that compete directly with
each other and the second question is
what do you expect from us as the
implementer of your products so a couple
of questions there first is analytics
obviously you know the web analytics
space is pretty complex especially when
you're doing SEO and things like that so
we've been working with a lot of early
access partners to try to close those
gaps because the way people think about
mobile app analytics is actually quite
different than the way they think about
mobile web analytics so we're continuing
to improve there you should see some
computed improvements in the pub site
particularly the other is around how you
think about maybe I miss a third
question but how you think about
selecting between these various
technologies at the end of the day the
way we think about it is that we want
developers to have the flexibility to
choose the right technology for them and
for developers a perfect example of this
is for games where there is no real
mobile web equivalent so you know we
want to make sure you have the
flexibility to do what's right for you
and for companies who are mobile first
and are really thinking about you know
building native apps we want to make
sure that they have the same capability
to bring that incident like experience
to two mobile web traffic or to you know
even the Play Store like we talked about
at the keynotes and then if you're on
the web and you want to focus on PWA or
em you know there
pros and cons of all of these various
approaches so it's kind of you know
about what's right for you as a
developer yeah but my concern is most of
the time when we are working like
Android team is working in web team
means working they might be working on
new feature and they might be working on
new feature it wasn't until the release
we knew like our sales gonna hinder each
other so we are in a competition with
each other because of the two two new
products release it's a fair question I
think one of the things to think about
is there's a technology choice in terms
of what what things you want but there's
also a distribution choice and the
different the different technologies
lend themselves to the distribution
method that your business is using so
that's why for game developers who are
used to a dish of distribution model
that comes from an app store instant
games is going to be a much more natural
choice from the distribution angle as
well as a technology angle if your
legacy say a shopping business and your
legacy is SEO and web then you come from
a legacy of technologies for our pw8 amp
might be more natural for you and if
your if your business is you know 80%
new visitors who are coming from SEO
you're probably not going to get those
guys to download the download an app for
certain queries so I would think about
it from a technology perspective and
then a distribution perspective and make
the right try to make the right choice
we understand that it's difficult and
and from a Google perspective you know
we want to give you the full suite of
tools and sometimes that means we can't
give you a canonical answer that's the
same for everybody because everybody's
situation is different
thank you Thanks hi hi
I'm quite interested in the flutter
framework so I was I had two questions
the first one is is it planned or is it
possible to have one module using
flutter so we can migrate some views in
it and maybe share it with our us
colleagues and the second question is
that I like flutter but is it possible
to make flutter with Catlin
[Applause]
[Music]
so I think I hear I didn't fully hear
the first question the first question
was can you use flutter and just part of
your app they said in a module and they
can work on iOS and then the second
question is you like flutter everybody
can use it with Coughlin somebody said
that should be called flutter so let's
see so so flutter is its own thing and
it's good you know I was actually really
impressed with the keynote like how many
people cheered and so it's getting
popular which I think it's great and
from my perspective on Android it's also
because the more options there are for
developers to write apps it's really
good and you know where we as a team are
investing in terms of toolkits is
jetpack compose which i mentioned
earlier and we we that's very much
column based obviously and also it's
designed to allow you to use it in parts
of your apps or all of your app and so
you can phase it in and so we really
thought about that sort of backward
compatibility and also you know being
language consistent with Kotlin but that
said you know just as I mentioned
earlier there's you know flutter has
some really nice aspects to it like it's
widget API is really nice how it's done
material and so we worked very closely
and so jetpack compose should look you
know somewhat familiar to you and so we
kind of try to share some of the best
practices and and idioms in some ways
yeah so that's kind of my indirect way
of answering your question I don't know
if anyone else wants to add
all right I'm watching politicians is
how they do it
hi all right
so Susan an active Android dev typically
had a good idea of the road Android is
heading towards and excited about all
the new tools but for new Android
engineers it can be nauseating trying to
wrap their head around all the new
approaches and filtering out the old
methodologies what can the team and
community do to make coming into Android
development easier examples
Scotland first jetpack composed
navigation our components flutter which
is also developed by Google and just
quickly outdated tutorials I'm not sure
what the actual question there was all
right what can you or the committee do
you to help what fine it's a great
question actually I don't know how many
of you there was an Android studio am a
month or two ago and this question came
up I thought it was a great one
essentially people saying look it's
great that you're making development
better but you've made it better and now
there's all this new stuff and I have to
learn all the new stuff and so holy cow
I gotta I gotta on board everybody do
this and so yes we've been talking about
this a lot in our team is how do we know
not just add documentation and samples
but also like holistically revamp
everything we have so let me let me try
this out on you wouldn't it be cool if
we're gonna be cool if you could come
into Android and instead of having to go
through what I sometimes call the layer
cake of like API 9 and 10 and 11 and 12
by the time you have read all the
documents about how it works on
different versions you kind of forgot
where you started you could just say
like look I just want to manage a
background task send me to the
documentation that tells me how to do
that you know look I just want to build
some you I just want to build navigation
and I think we're thinking a lot about
how to improve all of our documentation
and samples and you know other
supporting information around that as
well as I think the work eat and the
team have done around simplifying the
libraries has just been I'm probably
biased but I think it's amazing so I
think we're thinking a lot about how to
lower that barrier to entry so that when
people are newer to Android development
it's straightforward
I would love feedback about what's
working and also what we can do better
Thanks I actually I would add to part of
the stuff that I eat and and team were
working on whether that was the
opinionated guide right and it's trying
to address that it's not just the
libraries but it's also how do you put
these things together in architecture
application appropriately so hopefully
we're getting better at that I would
argue that we're not done like you're
trying our best is also a little bit
challenging because like you know your
use case the best so it's very hard to
give like super generic advice so if
we're really trying to learn this I
caught the last two three years I think
we got better so I work with the
community now we moved compost to the
open source we got a lot more code
reviews and help from the community and
I think if we can work together with
like y'all engineers and people in our
team that will get a lot better or time
yeah jetpack is intended to be our
opinionated answer it was kind of the
the one to to remember Diane wrote that
really famous posts that were not
opinionated to which you all replied
please be opinionated and that's
basically what jetpack is and we want to
keep building on that so that people you
do have a sense of like look this is the
way we recommend doing it you can always
drop down to the raw we sometimes call
the laws of gravity to the raw framework
we always want to leave you that power
but also provide a more elegant fast way
of getting things done all right I'm
gonna dip into online questions here I
thought this one was kind of an
interesting discussion point with
regards to a device like the Samsung
Galaxy fold who starts that conversation
is it Samsung or Google like hey we'd
like to build a fold of the dice any
chance you can support bendy phones in
the OS
bendy phones bendy phones bendy votes
you know what I've noticed like in the
last sort of decade the way this goes is
really it's actually the supply chain
that comes up with some technology
whether it's like a fingerprint sensor
or you know folded bendable displays
flexible displays and and the supply
chain puts it out there and then the
device makers so look at it like ooh
what could we do there and then we get
involved and we're like oh let's think
how the software works and so that's
that's kind of a pretty consistent
pattern what we've seen so like I you
know we would have seen flexible
displays a couple of years ago from the
display manufacturers and then you know
a year or two later we would see device
makers trying things out and then we
would get involved but you know I
actually pretty excited about the
foldables I think you know you know
we've been talking a lot about you know
phones folding into tablets and I think
that's you know roughly inform factors
but I actually think there's a lot more
ideas still to come that'll be quite
surprising that I'm pretty excited about
and so yeah I'm just thinking like this
time next year they'll they actually
quite a few cool things to talk about in
that space yeah anyone else one that and
then eventually marketing people get
involved and they say you know what how
about not bendy phones
how about foldables better yeah all
right
yes right oh hi yeah I was I'm currently
working on a native calling app and I
was wondering if there's an API
available to access the voicemail system
kind of like the for the video the
visual voicemail so that I can pull
voice mail or email audio data no thanks
I'm not most of the visual voicemail
services use IMAP so if you get a
regular IMAP client in theory you can
talk to them but I'm not fully sure what
the credentials are I'm sure carriers
have yeah but it's an IMAP client as a
choice okay so there's no telephony API
for that No
not that I'm aware of because it's also
like because it's a pretty rich client
you wouldn't want to bake it into the
framework because it changes a lot and I
know that different visual voicemail
services have different quirks and stuff
so okay thank you thanks hi hello there
was a distinct lack of mentioned about
where or less in either keynote or
anywhere in the column in the conference
is this a dead platform should we be
worried no but where is the where team
do everyone here
did I just make your point no oh we have
a sandbox yes
so no they're alive alive and kicking in
a sandbox at i/o no it's something we're
continuing to invest in we're really
excited by wearables actually and what
could I say you know we've actually
hired more people and we're investing
thank you thanks thank so hello I've
noticed that IO and in increased effort
on diversity and inclusion and many
talks about it and I want to know if
there's anything you're doing for just
to increase diversity inclusion in the
Android platform or even just amongst
your own teams that's a great question
you know so I've been spending a lot of
time in the medical industry lately in
hospitals and the striking thing that I
noticed is that you know when you know
when doctors do rounds and they and
whatnot striking striking thing I notice
is how balanced and in fact female heavy
just give one angle of diversity it is
and then I come back you know these
really strong to smart doctors and then
I come back to work and and it really
you know the diversity in the software
industry is really quite skewed and it's
something we have to fix and it's not
it's it's not like because you live in a
bubble and you can be like well the
world needs to be more diverse or
something but this industry specifically
like we really do need to improve it and
so you know we have a bunch of
initiatives that we're working on but
fundamentally we need to get you know we
need to get more diverse people into
into the hiring chain so we can hire
more people you know I one of one of the
arguments and we spent a lot of time in
Google in trying to increase diversity
both in the company and within our team
but it feels like a bit of a zero-sum
game so we're gonna try to do better and
and but
other companies are gonna suffer like we
need to work at this at a sort of an
industry level so that's good you know
that's just one or two of the things I
think other people on this panel should
talk to this point to because it's so
important I know a lot of people have
opinions I can just say briefly one of
the things I was really proud of is
Google is actually the first company
first tech company to publish our
numbers on diversity and I think that
was really amazing because then that
kicked off all other companies to create
kind of do the same thing and I think
having that transparency there's a this
is saying sunshine is the best
disinfectant just looking at the numbers
I think causes people to be aware and
start to change I think there's a lot of
opportunity for change still but it's
been really amazing to see especially on
the Android team there's like a lot of
very strong leaders at Diane many many
people on the team and yet I think it's
a place we can continue to invest the
other thing I would add is you know it's
it actually makes business sense like if
you're building a product you want a
diverse set of opinions you're gonna
build better products and and just so
you know from a very fundamental level
it makes a lot of sense you also have
better teams if you have a more diverse
set of teams and different opinions
you're gonna have a better healthier
team and so it's actually good for
business to do this as well but you know
like I said I think this industry needs
to work harder on it and you know
there's a there's a couple of beacons
which I get excited about I want to
great offer last year and you know it's
just amazing to see you know the the the
the there are you know there are diverse
aspects people in this industry but we
need more and put events like that are
really good to encouraging people to
join but a great question thank you
thanks speaking of Diane I'm gonna toss
one you are way walking down inefficient
Android API such as background services
implicit broadcast receivers and file
will also reduce the amount of developer
innovation is the Android team worried
about that trade-off have smartphones
matured to the point that not much
innovation remains
very good question and so first of all I
understand it is really painful when we
change things like this and remove some
of the freedom you have to do things and
put more elusive things on it's also
very important and it's actually been
kind of a fundamental part of Android
from the beginning when we first did
Android you know we had you know we had
application sandboxing from the very
beginning which was a huge change from
how operating systems you know
traditionally have worked it's like
greatly restrict applications and it's
very important for us to like we have
this balance between freedom of
developers how open of an ecosystem we
can have and what the user experience is
and so things like application
sandboxing allow us to do things like by
having restrictions in the platform we
can have a more open ecosystem instead
of having something like where someone
is sitting there approving every single
application
you know like with arbitrary rules about
whether couldn't be installed we can
have a more open store we can have you
know side loading of applications and
that kind of stuff and we are always
having to kind of find the balance
between these things so as our ecosystem
grows and changes problems come up where
we have issues especially around user
experience so for a good example of this
is the is background restrictions we're
finding that's increasingly battery life
on the devices gate was getting bad
because applications had total freedom
to do stuff in the background and you
give them freedom to do stuff and
they're gonna do it and every operative
L per is thinking like well this is
important for my application so I should
do it and you put everything together
and you know things get bad for the user
so as we see these problems and this
becomes a problem for everyone because
if users aren't happy with Android then
they're gonna leave Android they're
gonna be you know not use their devices
as much so we kind of need to addresses
in the platform so that's why we do
these kind of things very like say okay
we can't let applications run this
freely anymore we need to have some
controls in the platform to lock that
down ultimately it's fair for everyone
but it does cause a lot of pain and it
does cause some restrictions on what
developers can do but we try hard to
like still have as much freedom as we
can
we we care deeply about compatibility
and I mean I think the soul of the
platform is we love developers if you
take if you forget everything else from
this IO just remember that like we love
developers and we really want to make it
as friendly a platform as possible Dave
actually talked about compatibility in
the dev summit keynote back in 2015
I remember that far back it's a
fundamental philosophy for us that we
really want to as much as possible
minimize change and yes this year there
is some change we actually had a great
conversation with our developer advisory
board and they said look you guys are so
careful if occasionally you need to make
changes just do a couple things one tell
me about it as early as possible give me
notice to tell me all the technical
information up front so I can prepare
and three tell me why you're doing it
and be really careful do it as little as
possible and that's what we've tried to
do but I think the big fear I've heard
from people with this IO is a few people
have said how you guys changing are you
gonna start breaking us all the time and
the answer is no we have not changed our
philosophy is the same we're gonna
always seek to minimize changes as much
as possible because we want you to be
able to focus on your own business is
that I feel okay other thoughts cool hi
hi I'm really excited about motion leo
and some of the stuff that can do so
thank you my questions about jetpack
compose and how are they gonna work
together is one gonna be deprecated at
some point so we really want constraint
layout in something like mushroom layout
and jetpack compose but the contract out
in mushroom nail team was apparently
busy building completely mushroom out so
it's one of those many meanings that we
decided to have after i/o to talk about
it and start thinking about it seriously
but yeah we wanted to happen somehow at
some points yeah oh boy okay thank you
thanks Mike so I've noticed it seems
like Google as a whole has become split
brain on what they feel is right for
Android development with this hard push
towards Kotlin as like a gods in
language as well as flutter
and both are really hard to ignore with
all the advancements that you guys are
making on both sides Colin with all of
its like functional features and things
like that
while flutter is really good with his
crops platform so I was wondering if you
could provide some guidance on like how
to decide as a developer which framework
to go with its what we said earlier it
depends on what you're focusing on as a
developer like flutter is a fantastic
cross-platform solution if that's what
you're looking for if you're building a
native Android experience we provide
Kathleen and will building your new
libraries for that we're improving our
IP is so against about the choice right
we we feel like one one single solution
will not make all of our developers
happy so we have multiple solutions so
so I was talking about the flutter
developers earlier at the sandbox and I
was it was difficult to get anything out
of them as far as why not flutter like
why use native / flutter if you would
have to write it twice so is there
anything that like you get out of
writing natively that is significantly
beneficial over using flutter so I mean
you will have you know it's designed by
the Android the sorry our IP I saw
designed by the Android teams you're
putting out gonna have all the newest
features first you can talk to all of
the Android API directly you don't
change in the run time you don't change
language so you have benefits there and
you and you get cuddling tor says yeah
and you know and and that's where we
focus all of our efforts or all of our
teams are focused on this being what we
think is the best experience on Android
but again I can no flutter if you're
looking for something else I
cross-platform that's a great solution
alright thank you thanks we got time for
one or two more we'll go as fast as we
can hi hi so what are your thoughts
regarding the amount of fragmentation
found across all of 20,000 or so Android
phones across all markets or yen's and
stuff and the choice the developers can
find when they
like sometimes I run into the choice
where I need to choose between
supporting an older API version and and
trying to make what I do compatible with
those older older versions versus just
stopping and just drawing the line and
supporting only like newer versions but
due to that amount of fragmentation I
only get like a chunk of the users where
I would get to the other choice yeah I
think there's a couple of things were
doing you know I mean first of all I
would say this is a pretty unsolved
problem at this scale to have an
operating system that's open source and
customizable and running on so much
different hardware and silicon but we're
doing a lot of work to improve the
situation so one is something we call
project travel by having a very distinct
hardware abstraction layer and so that
when a device maker wants to move to a
new version of Android the new version
of Android just runs on top with a
minimal work and you can see some
progress on that so you know with the
beta this year we have what was the
numbers like 23 devices I think
including all the pixels that are
running on the beta of Q and that's and
that's like four times more than four
times more and sorry so that's that's
double what it was last year which is at
doubled the year before and then on top
of that if you look at PI there's four
times as many devices on PI now than
there was Oreo at the same time last
year and then the other interesting stat
is there's 40 percent more devices on PI
than there where devices on o at the
same time and the reason and that's a
direct example of why trebles helping
it's much easier to do this and so we're
we're just putting a lot of effort into
into that area and we do a lot of
programs we work with the silicon
vendors and so that we give them a
standard build of Android and so that
helps reduce version fragmentation but
it's an ongoing thing it looks like
it'll keep getting better but it takes a
lot of work I mentioned earlier about
main lines for consistency so we can
have more consistent modules and then on
top of that jetpack if you think of that
as a veneer on top we do a lot of the
work like camera X to try to abstract
you I think I come Rex works from
lollipop
we try to abstract you from a lot of the
complexity and the quirks that went
across those different API versions so
we're doing multiple things and I think
as I said probably on the first question
is you know this is clearly more work
for us to do but it's something we we
care about and they're investing in this
is like a major focus area for us so
like if you try to use more JPEG
libraries like all these background
restrictions work major tries to hide
the problems from you that so you don't
need to deal with the api's and when we
create a compatibility library we try to
implement it even in the older versions
even if we don't have the api's and so
the more you can use JPEG in your
libraries the less you care about
fragmentation great thank you thank you
unfortunately we ran out of time I had
one really quick question that I wanted
to ask Arash
and then we're gonna wrap it up when
will Google Play in-app update api's be
available for developers to use now so
thanks Twitter and thanks all of you
[Applause]
[Music]
you